Did Jesus ever say that God is tree
willing? Is what? Willing or whatever
the word means, tree willing. How do you
say it? Triune? Triune God. Did Jesus
ever say that God is triune?
Don't laugh at me because of how I said
it, bro. Come on.
>> bro. I feel like you did that to a
purpose, bro. It's a simple question,
bro.
>> You're right, it's a simple question.
Did he Are you asking if he used the
word triune tree willing? Yes.
Yes.
Uh he never used the word tree willing.
I don't think I don't think anybody has.
Is Are you a heretic or
A heretic? Can you be a Muslim and Islam
not be your religion? Yes or no?
>> 100%. Woo! [snorts]
100%. There's Trinitarian Muslims.
There's Trinitarian Muslims? But they
But Islam is not the religion because
they don't believe in tawhid. I got you.
I got you. One guy, I debated him. He
said there's some people Muslims who
believe in the Trinity. I was like, what
is that? Muslims who believe in in tree
willing God? If I said in the name of
Allah and Jabril and Muhammad, is that
associating Muhammad and Jabril with
Allah? I'm telling you what Jesus said.
>> Answer the question.
>> are associating. Yes. Yes.
>> Thank you. If I say in the name of the
Father and the Son and the Holy Spirit,
did I just associate the Son and the
Spirit with the Father? But you just
said that statement
>> Answer the question. When it equates to
something else, no.
>> Answer the question.
>> When that statement equals something
else
>> I didn't say that the statement equals
something. I'll do it again. Yes, you
did say
>> When I say in the name You just said, if
I say in the name of Allah and Jabril
and Muhammad, I just associated Muhammad
and Jabril with Allah. So I ask the same
thing, I just input it different
characters. If I say in the name of the
Father, the Son and the Holy Spirit, did
I just associate the Son and the Spirit
with the Father by that statement? No.
Because What it What it equals
>> why. You are You are incredible. Hey,
man, this is why you the face of Dawah,
man. A few moments later. If he says it
in the Christian sense, it's 100% shirk.
But if he says
>> just the statement alone, bro. Forget a
Christian sense, the statement. If Jesus
makes the statement in the name of the
Father, the Son,
>> that statement. is that shirk? If he If
he makes that statement, yes. Yeah, oh,
it is? Yes. Now, let's say he did make
the statement.
>> Jesus being a Muslim. Does Jesus ever
say the word tawhid? Bro, you should
take those glasses off, bro. Your
performance is horrible tonight. You're
right. Does Jesus ever say the word
tawhid? Is Jesus invisible to you? Yes.
Does Jesus ever say the word tawhid?
Bro, this is ridiculous. Jesus says one,
which is the root word of tawhid. Tawhid
>> that's not what I asked. I didn't ask if
he said one. Does Jesus say the word
tawhid?
>> Is the word tawhid in the Quran? No. So,
why Why would Jesus need to say So,
answer the question. Is that yes or no?
If If the Quran does not have the word
tawhid, why would Jesus need to say
tawhid? So, So, the answer is no, Jesus
doesn't say tawhid? Of course, he didn't
speak Arabic, and the word tawhid is an
Arabic word. Does this mean that because
Jesus never said the word tawhid, he
never used the word tawhid, does that
mean he never taught it? No. Very good.
So, just because cuz like The reason why
I'm asking is cuz in your in when you
asked me in your cross-examination, you
asked me, "Did Jesus ever use the word
Trinity?"
>> Did Jesus ever say that God is triune?
You used those questions to try to argue
that Jesus never taught the Trinity
because he never said the word Trinity,
and he never taught that he was God or
worthy of worship because he never said
the words, "I am God, worship me." So,
you just destroyed your entire method of
argumentation, bro. We got him. I asked
you about the triune God, and you said
no, he did not say Bro, try try you. I'm
trying to help you out. Try you. What
does Islam mean? Does it mean to submit
your will to the Father in heaven? Yes.
What does Islam mean? Tell me Tell me
the meaning. Why are you laughing? If
you refer to Allah by a name that does
not belong to him, is that deviation?
From Islam, it's considered as a form of
innovation, yes.
That's jahiliyyah.
>> Okay. So, if now if a Muslim If you call
God father, you're misinformed, you're
misguided. Very good. So very good. If
you call Allah father, you are misguided
and misinformed. So here's my question
to you. You quoted the Bible where Jesus
prostrates himself and according to the
verse that you put on your screen, it
says that going a little further, Jesus
fell on his face and prayed saying, "My
father, if it be possible, let this cup
pass from me, but not my will, let your
will be done." So according to what you
just said, that if you are calling Allah
What language did he say that in? What
language did he say that in? It doesn't
matter. Aramaic, okay? So he didn't
>> if you're saying He didn't say father
then. Yes, he did. He said Abba. Abba
means father in Aramaic. Okay, I I I
already If he says, hold on. Let Let me
ask the question. So when he says that
God is his father while he prays and
prostrates, and according to you, as you
agreed, if you call Allah your father,
you are misguided and misinformed. Was
Jesus misguided when he prostrated
himself and called God his father in his
prayer? was exclusive to the English
word father, which Jesus did not use. It
says you said Aramaic, right? Aramaic is
different. If Okay, in Aramaic he says
he would probably be called Aramaic it
says Abba father. It says Abba father in
the Aramaic. Do you want to see it?
What's wrong with that? Okay, he calls
God his father. So my question is is
Jesus misguided? Do not try to equate
the two just to make your point. This
doesn't make any sense. You're trying to
equate the word Abba directly with the
word father. That's what the word means,
dude. That's not what the word literally
means. There is
>> What is What does Abba mean? It's a
simplification that happens when you
translate it to English. Can you give me
the definition of Abba? Abba means
Hold on, one second. Let me search it
up. Yeah, search it up. Abba, right?
Which is a variant spelling of Abba. And
Abba as a noun is a title of honor given
variously to the fight the deity in the
New Testament, to bishops and patriarchs
in many Eastern churches, and to Jewish
scholars in the Talmudic period. Do you
see what it says? That's literally what
I read.
>> No, you didn't. You skipped this part
for some reason.
>> I didn't skip the part. I read the
definition of the word, dude. So, does
it mean father? Let's Let's open up
Google and search the definition of
father.
>> on Merriam-Webster's as you went to. Is
that the definition of father on Google?
That's not the definition of father.
>> does Does Abba mean father according to
Merriam-Webster's dictionary? Click on
it. Show me the definition of father.
Does Abba mean father according to this
definition? Show me the meaning of the
word father, cuz this is not the
definition of the word father, buddy.
Junior, are you Are you okay Are you
okay, dude? Are you okay, bro? This is
not the definition of the word father.
When it gives the definition of Abba,
when it gives the definition here
>> the definition of the word
>> What does it say that Abba means
according to Merriam-Webster's
dictionary? We have 1 hour back and
forth, and you're already
>> So, if you can answer this, bro, I'll
hand it over to you. I'll I'll let you
leave.
>> understand why you're playing games
right now.
How am I playing games? Buddy, what's so
funny? This is not the definition of
father. Go on Google
>> Well, then why is Merriam-Webster's
dictionary giving the meaning of Hold
on. Why is Merriam-Webster's dictionary
Dude, 1 second. up the word father. Now
Now you're mad at me.
>> Hold on. Hold on, Junior. Let him Let
him get his point off real quick on
this. You went to Merriam-Webster's
dictionary, Junior. And now that you're
seeing that it says father in plain
sight, you're panicking for some reason.
Relax. Let's chill. I'm literally asking
you to define father. What do I got to
define father? The question was, what is
the definition of Abba? What I'm sorry.
What does Abba mean? And you said it
doesn't mean father. So, can we agree
that according to Merriam-Webster's
dictionary, it means father, right?
Dude,
is this the definition of father next to
the word?
And I agreed to an hour of this. I don't
know what these two dots mean, bro. I'm
being I'm being real with you. I'm
genuinely not trying to troll, bro.
You're not going to trap me into this
answer, bro.
>> Does Merriam-Webster's dictionary Yes.
For the For the sake of time, yes. Let's
just move on. What does Jesus say the
will of the Father is? What does Jesus
say? Why don't you show me in the Bible
where he mentions the will of the
Father? In John chapter 6 verse 40, he
says, "For this is the will of my
Father, that everyone who looks on the
Son and believes in him should have
eternal life, and I will raise him up on
the last day."
>> How can I look at the Son if you if he's
invisible?
>> He's going to come and demonstrate
himself in an invisible form. There you
go. So, now So, now he's not
Does this match Islam? You just decided
that the Son is not
God
Does this match Islam, bro? No,
absolutely not. So, can you Can Jesus be
a Muslim? paganism Hold on. This was the
hell So, Jesus is teaching a doctrine
that goes against Islam. Can you teach a
doctrine that goes against Islam and be
a Muslim? Absolutely. You're an enemy of
Islam if you teach a doctrine.
>> Very good. You just admitted that Jesus
is an enemy as of Islam. He's not a
Muslim.
>> Jesus is a Muslim, and that's the
Now, we're going to go into the Q&A. How
How would you guys like to do the
format? Super chats?
>> care, bro. Super I don't care. Just
let's go to the questions, bro. Junior
Junior, next question, brother.
>> [laughter]
>> Seems like there's a lot of questions,
so Yes, there's a lot of questions. Yes,
this is a Q&A.
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> What about these questions, bro?
>> [laughter]
>> I'm sorry, man. I don't know the format
of this debate, bro.
This debate was all over the place, man.
7-minute opening versus 5-minute
opening, 10-minute rebuttals, 1 hour
shortened to 45 minutes. Now we're doing
random Q&As, so Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay. So, all right, look. I ain't going
to lie, man. What
>> [laughter]
>> Come on, moderator. I'm I'm hoping
someone will take the Shahada, but maybe
maybe my hopes are too high with this
audience, but I mean
>> you you did a you did a great job. Maybe
somebody might.
>> You might remember me from last week. I
was the questioning Muslim. After the
debate and seeing how dishonest Jay is,
I have decided that I must leave Islam.
My question is this. Wow.
>> Can you better explain how Jesus taught
the Trinity and baptism so I can follow
it better? Yeah, 100% 100%. So, shout
out to the sister Ines Layla. I do
remember you. So, God bless you and I
praise God for for your testimony and
you being brave enough to to come to
Christ and take that leap of faith. So,
absolutely. So, notice [clears throat]
in the in in in where where Jesus is
saying, he says that all authority has
been given unto me in heaven and on
earth. Therefore, go out and make
disciples of all nations baptizing them
in the name one name one singular name,
right? It's singular in the Greek. The
name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. So, the Father, Son, and
Holy Spirit are united and share in that
one name that that one divine power and
authority. Jesus puts himself and the
Holy Spirit with the Father in that
authority, in that power, in that
nature. So, this is one of the places
where Jesus is is teaching the Trinity.
More places, you have Jesus, for
example, where he says that he's going
to when he goes away, this is John
chapter 14, John chapter 15, and chapter
16. Specifically, you want to see like
John chapter 15 verse 26. Jesus says
that he's going to send the Holy Spirit,
the spirit of truth. He's going to send
the comforter, the Holy Spirit, who
proceeds from the Father. Means he comes
from the Father's essence. The Holy
Spirit comes from the Father's essence.
So, he he's he has the same essence as
the Father. So, you have the all three
persons are included there. You have the
son who is going to send the Holy Spirit
from the father who comes out of the
father. So, there Jesus is again
teaching the Trinity. In other places he
teaches in John chapter 5 for example,
he says that the son does nothing by
himself but only what he sees the father
doing. For whatever the father does,
that the son does the same exact way.
So, Jesus just teaches that he doesn't
work alone. He's inseparable from the
father and is able to do whatever the
father is able to do in in divine
actions and attributes, right? So, he
does nothing he never works alone. He's
inseparable from the father. Everything
they do they do together and he's able
to do whatever the father does teaching
that he himself is divine and shares the
essence of the father. So, we could do
this on a longer stream. I don't have
much time in this but come in another on
another stream and I can break down the
divinity of Christ and the Trinity
throughout the Bible, the father, son,
Holy Spirit being united as one God.
I'll be happy to show you these things.